yeah you say point to the paint and
rebounds Nicole jokic 28 points 16
rebounds four assists just four missed
shots in our closeout game Sam those are
Joker's numbers after a slow first half
that he had foul trouble uh what do you
make of the way that Nicola jokic played
in the closeout I think he's starting to
accept separate himself as being one of
the greatest players look at this right
here I love this offense Mike Malone
runs a play that's kind of misdirection
that gets Miami off tilted they don't
talk The Joker comes off how many
coaches can run a set play for his
Center to come off and knock down a
three again look at this offensive set
he starts everything by getting in
position now think about this if you're
gonna give the joke of two three four
five dribbles the crab dribble into the
paint and then the double team come it's
too late and for Kyle man it's just the
elbow in the chalks right there get on
out the way you're too late again this
offense finding the soft spots in his
own he takes the contact and shoots a
away one jump shot and then again
last but not least here he comes he set
always starts everything by setting a
good screen and then he finds the weak
spots in his own Kayla Martin you think
you're going to be able to switch on me
nope you're just too little and look at
that burst of speed and quickness to
take a smaller guy off the dribble the
thing for me that was so outstanding is
he could take you outside and shoot the
three he can take you inside against his
own you put him in the middle his
passing just cussed like a a warm knife
through butter and then he can just
score he had the answers to every test
that Eric's supposed to in this Miami
coaching staff gave him and he aced it
he's the best player in the NBA by far
we always talk about Batman and Robin
right but with the joker we gotta find
his henchmen that's Jamal Murray uh you
look at what he did in the closeout game
16-8-8 I believe great series for him
also had a 30-point triple double in
this series I like the way he played
with pace and he played with passion but
at the same time he played with
intensity coach when he attacked the rim
he had moments of being like fiery and
he showed his emotions to the crowd
there was other moments he would tell
his teammates to slow down and calm down
we're seeing one of the best point
guards in the NBA develop in front of
our eyes and he is on that platform
right now because he has the ring
against the title and he has youth
behind him because he has a roster where
he can compete every season